what I'm saying is that being a
citizen also means accepting the duties that
go with this citizenship and so
when you're a citizen you have to accept to
fulfill your duty
then yes I fully assume and that's
what we do  Basically, since last summer,
we have had a strategy that is simple
vaccinate vaccinate vaccinated it is
European and therefore we can be moved
by forms of expression that
seem familiar that I
totally assume myself I am moved by the
situation in  which we are the
real fracture of the country alas when
some make their freedom which
becomes one of my responsibilities a
slogan not only do they
endanger the lives of others but they
restrict the freedom of others
it is a question of I cannot  accept and
therefore this movement you see it everywhere
in europe so some make
the vaccination obligation above a
certain age but most countries
put constraints on social life
by saying if you are not
vacated  movies you don't have access to this place
you don't have access to this activity
and we have to do this to
encourage each other alpha and
we have to do this we have to
do this for all of our
compatriots who make the effort to
get vaccinated and who, through
the irresponsibility of certain others,
sometimes the choices assumed are contaminated
and we must also do this for our
compatriots who sometimes let themselves be
taken in by obscurantist discourse
by discourse of fear and not
not protect themselves, whereas
science, research and
European technological and productive excellence
allow them